I know Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom
aren't saying I do just yet but a source
does tell ET they have started thinking
about their big day
the lovebirds got engaged on a
helicopter on Valentine's Day we landed
on a rooftop my whole family was oh
that's great he did so well now a source
tells ET that perry and bloom quote have
started planning their wedding but there
is no rush
both have been married before and know
what they want to do different this time
[Music]
bloom was married to Miranda Kerr from
2010 to 2013 and the two have an
eight-year-old son Flynn and Perry was
married to Russell Brand from 2010 to
2012 I was really addicted to love you
know the love of that someone could give
me not the love I had for myself and I
got so addicted to it that when that
love was taken away from me I felt like
I couldn't live the source ads that
kaboom is just focused on enjoying their
life together the couple is serious
about their future
but they aren't stressing about
hammering everything out now Katy and
Orlando are both very busy and when
things slow down they will get married
but right now there is no set date we
are so happy for Leo I mean what made
him you know that he was the one for you
oh thank you very much it's just obvious
and while they may not be rushing down
the aisle a source previously told ET
that the two are quote over the moon
about this chapter in their relationship
adding quote they talked about an
engagement even before their breakup in
2017 but Katie wasn't ready after some
time away she knew Orlando was the right
man for her life everyone
in a relationship that's how we see it
now and we've taught each other a lot
the two met in 2016 at a Golden Globes
after-party so I had my security guard
grabbed and in and out oh my god and all
the sudden I see my boyfriend's pan
he wasn't even sitting at our table he
just swoops in and he grabs it and I'm
like hey that's my Peru during a stop by
Jimmy Kimmel Live in February the singer
revealed it was love at first bite he
stole one off of my table I was sitting
with Denzel Washington and he took it
and I was like woo oh you're so hot
fine take it and then I saw him at a
party and I was like how are those
onions resting on your molars it's like
I like you and then you know cut to that
impressive engagement bling is estimated
to have cost a whopping two million big
ones
[Music]
and while in-and-out is responsible for
setting off fireworks
[Music]
Orlando is all about creating a healthy
lifestyle for he and his bride
Orlando on Instagram the man works out
Lando is like he looks good I mean he's
always trying to get me to hike yoga eat
vegan oh my god it is like I'll hike to
Taco Bell with you
I sure will Crunchwrap supreme x-treme
extra onion
[Music]